مع الوزير بالعوده الى الرابعه عشر من
يناير كيف تصرفت عندما علمت من التلفزه ان
الرئيس غاده
تصرفت هو اول شيء سالت سي محمد الغنوشي
لان بيناتنا الوزير الاول قلت له السيد
الوزير الاول هل حقيقي
همم
وبعدين همم
اه لم يكن يعني متحفا بل هو هو كان متحفظا
في شيء لان في اللحظه التي اجابني هذا
الجوال هو كان يستعد
للذهاب الى كارتاج
النيابه على الرئاسه على الفصل 56
ولم لم لم يعلم بذلك اوليس
الاول
هكذا وبعدين وقع ما وقع اليوم الموالي
وانتقل
في تغطياتنا مشروعيه 57
عندما كنت تابع ذلك
ولكن لم انظر اليهم لانني لا ادعي الفقه
في القانون انا رجل علم اجتماع
ولكن هؤلاء عملوا مع الرئيس هذا هل انصفوا
البلاد بان تسلم السلطه مكانه ام انهم
تسرعوا او نفذوا مخططات او ساعدوا مخططات
هو كل ما تبين فيما بعد لان فيما بعد له
حتى الاتصالات حتى بيني وبين السيد محمد
الغنوشي الوزير الاول بقيت لايام وحتى مع
فوائد الايام ثم انقطعت مع شي ياخذوا
الهاتف الى اخره
لعبه اخرى شو يعني لعبه
اللعبهم كثيرا من الخارج وستقبل ودخلوا في
ال- في ال- في المفاوضات الى اخرها ودخلوا
للاداره ودخلوا الى وزاره الداخليه الى
اخره يعني
اسلاميه النهضه ومن معها ومن
والاها كما يقول ابن خلدون مع ان يوالها
بدون ان يكون اخوانا وحتى اسلاميه
الذين كانوا يعملون مع الرئيس
الحكومه اعضاء الحكومه قلت لك الحكومه حلت
منها 13 لا اقصد الاول والسيد فؤاد
كيف اشرح لي اكثر يعني سلوكه اتصالاتنا في
اتجاهي لان انا كان اتسالات بسيطه واعرف
ان
لا اعرف بالضبط من احاطه بنفسه مثلا
الوزير الاول والا بعدين
الرئيس المؤقت الى اخره هذه الاشياء دارت
فيما بعد دون ان اكون متابعا لها عن قرب